with liberals having monopolized the
fields of journalism academia and the
entertainment industry for decades you'd
think they'd be happier people but
they're really not in the age of Trump
many Democrats hardcore political
activists and the elites in the
entertainment industry just seemed plain
miserable and perpetually angry Donald
Trump is a guy who you understand he
hurts you and you in my testosterone
sometimes makes me want to feel like
punching him like we need somebody that
can take this guy on well can you punch
him in the face well they all mouth
platitudes about loving diversity but
increasingly they want none of it
meaning they want conservatives banished
altogether from the public square
treated like I don't know political
lepers so if you're a trump supporter
you shouldn't even be allowed to do a
guest spot on a TV show number after
word broke that former White House press
secretary Sean Spicer would be a
contestant in the new season of Dancing
with the Stars host Tom Bergeron
protested my preference it's not my call
other people booked the show would have
been to avoid any political lightning
rods I think dancing at its best is an
oasis away from all the divisive nough
sand all of the stuff that we're all
wrestling with right now
wrestling dancing and right on cue
reporters at CNN vomited out this
headline check it out
well it cites nine unnamed sources
affiliated with ABC's news division and
one source said it's disgusting to think
he's getting on the show and getting
paid by our company first it's really
the shareholders company idiot second
about half of them will probably vote
for Trump and what's truly disgusting
is the rabid partisanship at formant
formally very respected news agencies
like ABC News after all no one had any
qualms did they about hiring George
Stephanopoulos from Bill Clinton's White
House and I likes George he's always
been kind to me when I've been on ABC
and we've got to remember he's not a
commentator he's one of the marquee News
hosts lefts fine with that but Sean
Spicer
I don't know what is he gonna be
attempting the tango it's somehow an
affront to their journalistic integrity
at ABC please and yesterday this is
unreal
the Miss Nevada pageant winner Katie
Williams was stripped of her crown after
she dared to express pro-trump views on
her personal social media accounts this
comes after many emails of the
coordinators emailing me saying that I
am quote too political to be in the
pageant when I would reply back and
asked what I could do or anything else
their basic answer was to delete
everything on my page I asked what was
the actual content that they didn't like
and they would never give me an answer
now which you've gotten booted if she
was let's say a climate change alarmist
or a Planned Parenthood supporter you
know the answer now Ms Williams will be
joining us in moments to tell us more
now even billionaire sports moguls
aren't safe from the leftist purge
patrol Miami Dolphins owner Steve Ross
is being ejected from the league social
justice committee by the way it's a
committee he founded the reason he dared
to host a Trump fundraiser
this blacklisting and intimidation and
public shunning is part of a pattern
that's intensified since the election of
Trump please
get up in the face of some Congress
people when they go low they go low we
kick and we know what that hateful talk
encouraged more peace and understanding
well we saw prominent conservatives
harassed in public these people don't
even want conservatives to be able to
relax in the sanctity of their own homes
hopefully some just in the heart and at
universities don't expect conservatives
will get treated any better
[Applause]
and if you're just a retiree or a small
business owner who donates to Trump's
campaign
you're also not immune you too could be
targeted and even doxed by your own
congressman no less I hope that these
donors in San Antonio and donors
throughout the country unless you
support the white nationalism and the
racism that Donald Trump is paying for
and fueling then I hope that you as a
person of good conscience will think
twice about contributing to his campaign
he's feeling the racism the same people
who blamed Trump's rhetoric for the
recent el paso mass shooting use as he
does the most vicious toxic language to
smear their political adversaries forget
real debate just smear them and it's all
with the goal of making them social and
cultural outcasts
[Music]
god be with you
now they probably send us all the leper
colonies if they could do you really
think most Americans support these
malicious efforts the their language I
don't
I think our citizens disagree vigorously
but they're very fair-minded people and
they don't like to see their neighbors
or friends on both sides of the aisle
living in fear of expressing their views
and so many conservatives today they
come up and tell me I'm really quiet
about what I believe I'm afraid of going
saying the wrong thing at work they're
all afraid all the time that's where the
left wants it the cultural and political
progressives though I think they ought
to be very careful because while
demonizing conservatives and driving
them underground may feel good to them
in the moment the nastiness may just end
up driving more voters into the arms of
Donald Trump and that's the angle